yeah that's right you you see it you
know you want to click it oh yep so
close just for those biscuits the
biscuits they're free just click just
just click on it cck the
bisc these targeted marketed survey
advertising clicking popup Windows
stupid why do I click them it's like
they know who I am they know what I like
they know what I want they know
everything I do want some free biscuits
from Red Lobster $10 off a Best Buy gift
card three equals
$30 click and I such a sucker for
clicking the surveys you guys want my
opinion you want to know what I think
great well I'm just going to tell you
but the worst part is when I'm actually
typing in a web address to go somewhere
and I type in YouTube or Twitter
incorrectly and has this popup but it's
a popup that won't ever go away as soon
as you close that one another one opens
up and you close that one and five more
open and once you close all five of
those 10 more pop up that's when they
really get you cuz they all these things
and there's just music playing in
there's videos playing and every
freaking pop up and I'm like oh my God
oh my God can somebody please put me out
of my
M no I don't want
any wait a minute
did that say I could get a free T-shirt
If I finished filling out that
survey and that's how they usually get
you they offer you something really
super sweet that you just can't turn
down and that my friends Mr popup ad
that's how you get me to do whatever you
want I actually decided Well if
everybody else can make surveys
why can't I make one so I wanted to make
one and I actually did make one I made
one and you guys can go to the link
below if you do decide to provide me
with your email address you'll have a
chance to win a free t-shirt from my
t-shirt store I have a ton of new
designs that my friend Mikey J made for
me I'm pretty excited about it because
actually they're really fun T-shirts if
you do finish the survey I made a little
bonus video soon as you finish the
survey it'll automatically direct you to
the secret video that I made I don't
know I've just been fascinated
with these freaking survey websites and
all of these ads that just pop up
because they seriously do know
everything like my favorite clothing
store is guest so every time I'm on a
website no pun intended but guess what
shows up guest shows up all the time and
I click it every single time every
single time every single time like
doesn't even matter doesn't even matter
if I want a new shirt or I want some new
shoes it just pops up hey guys I'm going
to go thanks for watching my video don't
forget about my fun little survey I love
you I'll see you guys when I see you
depending upon what you say in the
survey depends on when I'm going to post
another video
mhmm mhm going to do a little dance
going to do a little dance
mhm I don't even know all right bye
thanks for watching my video hope you
liked it be sure to subscribe so you'll
know when I post another one and check
out some other stuff there's a bunch of
annotations so get
clicking
n